[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen wir haben jetzt 20
Minuten Nachrichten für Sie mit dem
Sport von Norbert Lehmann
als erstes aber der Blick nach
Großbritannien dort wird schon wieder
ein neuer premier gesucht
gescheitert nach nur 45 Tagen die
britische Premierministerin List Trust
tritt zurück das polit-chaos in London
geht in die nächste Runde
der doppelwumms und sein Echo in Europa
beim EU-Gipfel will der Kanzler Bedenken
und Sorgen der anderen ausräumen
[Musik]
und ein Flüchtlingsheim steht in Flammen
der Verdacht Brandstiftung 14
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine darunter
auch Kinder verlieren ihre Unterkunft
noch nie hat jemand in Großbritannien so
kurz regiert wie sie nach nur rund sechs
Wochen als britische Premierministerin
hat List tras heute ihren Rücktritt
verkündet sie wolle noch so lange im Amt
bleiben bis ein Nachfolger ernannt
worden sei sagte die konservative
toripolitikerin in ihrem kurzen
Statement vor dem Amtssitz in der
Downing Street über den Rücktritt und
die Reaktionen Yasin herlein
es ist zumeist ein schlechtes Zeichen
wenn dieses Pult vor Nummer 10 Downing
Street aufgebaut wird dann wird
wichtiges verkündet in diesen
turbulenten Zeiten meistens Rücktritte
der von distras war nur eine Frage der
Zeit gewesen
wir hatten die Vision für eine
Wirtschaft mit niedrigen Steuern und
hohem Wachstum mit der wir die Vorteile
des brexit nutzen wollten ich habe
angesichts der bestehenden Situation
aber eingesehen dass ich den Auftrag mit
dem ich von der konservativen Partei
gewählt wurde nicht erfüllen kann
jene Partei die immer mehr im Chaos
versinkt bei einer Abstimmung am
gestrigen Abend war es zu tumultartigen
Szenen gekommen als konservative
Abgeordnete angeblich mit physischer
Gewalt dazu gezwungen wurden für die
Regierungspolitik zu votieren
das ist Chaos eine Schande was hier
passiert unglaublich entsetzlich ich
sollte das nicht sagen aber ich hoffe
dass alle die geholfen haben dass Trust
premier wird dass es sich für Sie
gelohnt hat einmal Minister einmal
wichtig zu sein am Kabinettstisch Platz
zu nehmen denn der Schaden den sie
unserer Partei zugefügt haben ist
ungemein
dabei saß gestern zunächst noch danach
aus als wenn sich Trust noch ein wenig
würde halten können bei der aktuellen
Fragestunde im Parlament schlug sie sich
einigermaßen achtbar dann aber wurde
bekannt dass die amtierende
Innenministerin ihren Hut nehmen musste
schon das zweite hochrangige
Kabinettsmitglied nach Finanzminister
quasiquateng
der hatte für jene Politik der
Steuersenkungen vor allem für Reiche
verantwortlich gezeichnet die von den
Finanzmärkten abgelehnt wurde das Pfund
Abstürzen ließ und inzwischen wieder
zurückgenommen ist mit all dem Messe
jetzt Schluss sein fordert die
Opposition das kann so nicht weitergehen
Großbritannien verdient besseres
Großbritannien kann das Chaos der
konservativen nicht mehr länger ertragen
wir brauchen Neuwahlen und zwar jetzt
doch die Konservativen wollen das wieder
einmal intern regeln bis Ende nächster
Woche
Großbritannien wird in diesem Jahr also
den dritten premier haben Andreas
stammen in London wie reagieren die
Britinnen und Briten darauf
ja die hatten die Urteil schon gefällt
listras war die unbeliebteste
Premierministerin aller Zeiten da wurden
Werte gemessen die es noch nie gab in
der Geschichte minus 70 und da geht es
durchaus Politiker die sich im
Plusbereich bewegen nur mal zum
Vergleich der einzige den sie ja der der
sie sozusagen noch überholt in
Unbeliebtheit ist Wladimir Putin bei -80
und das gilt auch für die Partei das
heißt neuwahlen sind ausgeschlossen denn
es droht ein Erdrutschsieg der
Opposition und ja bis zu 300 der 360
Tory Abgeordneten könnten ihr Mandat
verlieren ein Wahlforscher hat es mal so
ausgedrückt der britische Wähler ist wie
ein Gorilla der still count in der Ecke
sitzt nicht das Treiben investments and
ten Downing Street hinter mir anschaut
aber wenn er sich in Bewegung setzt dann
macht er alles nieder heute hat er lässt
was niedergemacht und niemand glaubt
dass die konservative Partei sich
wirklich von diesem Schock nicht nur von
listrasse sondern der vergangenen sechs
Jahre wird wirklich erholen können also
ein immenser politischer Schaden bevor
wir gleich darüber reden wie es
weitergeht schauen wir mal kurz auf den
Preis der Tories in der Downing Street
seit dem brexit David Cameron er will
den Austritt aus der EU eigentlich gar
nicht taktiert aber mit der Abstimmung
und muss dann 20 16 gehen sein Erbe
tritt die glücklose Theresa May an sie
verhandelt mit der EU den
austrittsvertrag der im Unterhaus aber
keine Gnade findet nach ihrem Rücktritt
2019 schlägt die Stunde von Boris
Johnson mit großen Worten gelingt ihm
ein spektakulärer Wahlsieg eher klein
bleiben aber seine Taten im Krach mit
der EU und in der corona-politik sein
Ende ein party-skandal zur Nachfolgerin
wählt die Partei List Trust sie
scheitert nun nach nur 45 Tagen die Toys
haben also wirklich keine gute Figur
abgegeben Andreas wie geht es weiter
ja vor wenigen Minuten hat das
zuständige Komitee der Toys bekannt
gegeben wie der ja der Auswahlprozess
nun genau laufen soll bis Montag können
sich Abgeordnete bewerben können ihren
Hut in den Ring werfen aber sie brauchen
die Unterstützung von mindestens 100
ihrer Kollegen im Parlament das setzt
ein enorm hohen
Standard und den werden nur ganz wenige
überschreiten vielleicht nur einer
vielleicht sogar dann wäre es direkt am
Montag erneuer Premierminister neue
Premierministerin vielleicht aber auch
zwei aber vor allem soll es eins
ausschließen das Boris Johnson
zurückkehrt denn der liebäugelt damit
aber man glaubt nicht dass er nachdem er
so viel verbrannte Erde im Parlament bei
seiner Fraktion hinterlassen hat
wirklich diesen Hunderter schaffen
könnte also es sieht danach aus dass bis
Montag eben die Kandidaten dann die
Unterstützung und wenn es zwei oder
vielleicht sogar drei Kandidaten geben
sollte dann wird in einer
Online-Abstimmung das Partei Volk
gefragt ungefähr 200.000 Tories die dann
darüber entscheiden das ging beim
letzten mal schief deswegen macht man
sogar noch ein Votum des Parlaments
Fraktion und sagt das ist unser Kandidat
und bitte bleibt bei diesem Kandidat
denn am letzten Mal hat die Parteibasis
anders entschieden sich für das Trust
und das ging mächtig schief Dankeschön
Andreas Damm
und mit dem Trust Rücktritt beschäftigt
sich auch ZDF heute live gleich um 19
Uhr im Interview unter anderem ein
britischer Abgeordneter auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und in der ZDF
heute App
klicken wir nach Brüssel dort Ringen die
eu-staats- und regierungschefinnen und
Chefs derzeit darum wie die hohen
Energiepreise in den Griff zu kriegen
sind vor allem Deutschland ist gegen ein
europäischen gaspreisdeckel und wird
dafür gerade von Frankreich heftig
kritisiert Kanzler Scholz und Präsident
macron trafen sich bereits vor dem
Gipfel zu einem Gespräch Gunnar Krüger
berichtet
zum Gipfel vor dem Gipfel kommt Olaf
Scholz pünktlich und Immanuel macron
eine Viertelstunde zu spät was zeigt
Europas Motor ist aus dem Takt der
Franzose sieht sich als Vermittler der
deutsche wirbte isoliert denn eine
Mehrheit der EU-Mitglieder will nicht
mehr als einen festgelegten
Einkaufspreis fürs Gas zahlen
wir haben da eine sehr große Einheit
also arbeite ich daran auch mit dem
Kanzler es ist weder für Deutschland
noch für Europa gut wenn Deutschland
sich isoliert
Scholz erträgt den Vorwurf als Lenker
der größten Wirtschaftsnation der EU
sorgt er sich um die
Versorgungssicherheit es ist auch so
dass wir natürlich gucken müssen dass
wir das was wir entscheiden so
einrichten dass es funktioniert niemand
möchte ja Beschlüsse fassen wo es
hinterher theoretisch gut ist aber kein
Gas gibt darum legt die EU-Kommission
heute nur ein preisdeckelchen auf den
gipfeltisch flexibel und vorübergehend
ein Scheinriese ist auch der Plan für
den gemeinsamen Einkauf von Gas denn
Europas Verbrauch entsprach zuletzt rund
5000 Terawattstunden davon wurden 1000
eingelagert nur von dieser Menge soll
die EU laut Vorschlag 15% gemeinsam
kaufen das wären nur 3% des
Jahresverbrauchs
und doch könnte auch so ein Kartell
gegen Wettbewerbsregeln verstoßen woran
Scholz sich stört andere nicht
wir haben schon so oft nein gehört
vielleicht hören wir jetzt ja mal ein
Jahr
die Staats- und Regierungschefs und
Chefinnen stecken in der Klemme zwischen
Handlungsdruck und Machbarkeit
und Roller warum ist denn so ein
europäischer gaspreisdeckel so
umstritten
der gaspreisdeckel ist eben zu diesem
zündstoffthema geworden weil hier die
nationalen Interessen aufeinanderprallen
im Prinzip will man ja hier aus Brüssel
ein Zeichen der Geschlossenheit bringt
aber die einzelnen Ländern wollen eben
auch ihre Wirtschaften unterstützen und
ihr Unternehmen unterstützen und da ist
die große Sorge vom Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz wenn man einen Gaspreis festsetzt
das ist dann eben nicht genug Gas gibt
dass das Gas woanders verkauft wird und
das wäre ein Riesenproblem gerade für
die deutsche Wirtschaft die sehr viel
Energie braucht und die anderen die
Mehrheit hier im EU unter den
EU-Mitgliedstaaten sind der Ansicht wenn
eben Deutschland bereit ist fast jeden
Preis für das Gas zu zahlen dann
bekommen sie eben kein Gas dass sie sich
leisten können weil Deutschlands
überbietet und deshalb braucht es einen
gaspreisdeckel also ihr prallen die
Interessen aufeinander und es ist zur
Stunde noch nicht abzusehen wie das mehr
oder weniger zusammengebracht werden
soll wahrscheinlich wird man ein
Prüfauftrag geben um das Problem eben
nicht eskalieren zu lassen müssen aber
eine Einigung ist nicht in Sicht danke
für diese Erläuterung nach Brüssel
vor dem EU-Gipfel hat Kanzler Scholz am
Morgen im Bundestag eine
Regierungserklärung abgegeben das große
Thema das 200 Milliarden Euro Programm
mit dem die hohen Gas- und Strompreise
in Deutschland abgefedert werden sollen
die Opposition ist damit nicht zufrieden
über die Debatte Andreas Huppert
von wegen sie reden nicht miteinander
der Kanzler und der Oppositionsführer im
Austausch vor der Debatte freundlich
entspannt in der Debatte erklärt dann
Olaf Scholz 28 Minuten lang seine Sicht
auf die Problemlage man lasse sich von
Putin nicht erpressen mit dem 200
Milliarden Rettungsschirm komme man gut
durch den Winter keine Familie keine
Rentnerin kein Student und auch kein
Unternehmen soll Angst haben vor den
Preisen für Strom Gast oder Fernwärme
überfordert zu werden unseren
Abwehrschirm haben wir bewusst auf
zweieinhalb Jahre angelegt um auch für
den nächsten Winter gewappnet zu sein
Friedrich Merz nimmt den Kanzler ins
Visier das Machtwort zur Kernkraft nötig
die Laufzeiten aber zu kurz Waffen für
die Ukraine zu wenig die Entlastungen
bei den Energiekosten zu spät
Winterreifen muss man im Oktober
aufziehen und nicht erst im Frühjahr des
nächsten Jahres jetzt brauchen die
Menschen und die Unternehmen in
Deutschland eine klare Antwort Kritik
die die Grünen nicht auf sich und der
ampelregierung sitzen lassen wollen
der 200 Milliarden Abwehrschirm der
gerade geplant wird sie sollten nicht
einfach nur sagen dass läuft nicht gut
machen Sie doch mal einen Vorschlag wo
sind sie denn da apropos Vorschlag die
linke Opposition hätte da ein außerdem
müssen alle Haushalte mit kleinen
Haushalt plus 600 Euro für jedes weitere
Haushaltsmitglied das würde wirklich
etwas bringen für die AFD ist der
Rettungsschirm nichts weiter als ein
gigantischer Schuldenberg die 200
Milliarden neues Sondervermögen sind
neue Schulden die am Ende der
Steuerzahler sowieso bezahlen muss gut
zwei Stunden Debatte und Streit über den
richtigen Weg aus der Krise am
Nachmittag gab es dann auch konkretes
mit großer Mehrheit beschließt der
Bundestag eine energiepauschale von 300
Euro für alle Rentnerinnen und Rentner
schauen wir noch einmal genauer auf das
Thema Gas da haben sich die bisherigen
Sparanstrengungen offenbar schon gelohnt
die Gasspeicher seien derzeit mit mehr
als 96% sehr gut und schneller als
erwartet gefüllt sagt die
Bundesnetzagentur und ist zuversichtlich
dass wir ohne gasmangel durch den Winter
kommen aber nur unter bestimmten
Bedingungen unter anderem müsse
Deutschland das Sparziel von mindestens
20% weiterhin einhalten um eine
mangelage zu verhindern
die Ukraine muss massiv Strom sparen als
Reaktion auf die anhaltenden russischen
Luftangriffe auf Kraftwerke und andere
energieeinrichtungen Präsident selenski
Bevölkerung dazu auf den Stromverbrauch
auf das Nötigste zu begrenzen nach
Regierungsangaben sind rund 40 Prozent
der Energieinfrastruktur zerstört viele
kleine Dörfer wie hier bei kamatosk sind
komplett von der Energieversorgung
abgeschnitten
viele Menschen aus der Ukraine suchen
Schutz in Deutschland in Groß strömken
Dorf im Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist eine
Unterkunft für ukrainische geflüchtete
abgebrannt niemand wurde verletzt der
Startschuss ermittelt es wird von
Brandstiftung ausgegangen und ein
politischer Hintergrund vermutet die
bundesinnenministerin reagierte entsetzt
die Einzelheiten von Anne Stadtfeld und
Susanne Seidel
wie Zunder brennt das Reetdach der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft lichterloh steigen
die Flammen in den nächtlichen Himmel
von großströnkendorf nahe Wismar alle 14
geflüchteten Ukrainer können unverletzt
entkommen der Schreck ist trotzdem
besonders groß
plötzlich muss man wieder mal sein Heim
verlassen man muss wieder mal um eigene
Sicherheit bringen und diese
Unsicherheit erneut erleben diese schon
mal erlebt haben der ehemalige
Hotelkomplex brennt komplett nieder
Teile des Hauses müssen wegen
Einsturzgefahr abgerissen werden schon
früh geht die Polizei davon aus dass das
Feuer absichtlich gelegt wurde außerdem
vermuten die Beamten einen politischen
Hintergrund der Tat sprechen im Moment
zwei Indizien für zum einen ist es eine
hakenkreuzschmiererei die hier am
vergangenen Montag festgestellt wurde
und zum anderen ist es natürlich der
Brandort hier im Flüchtlingsheim ist zum
Brandort geworden am Nachmittag trifft
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer am
abgebrannten Flüchtlingsheim ein im Fall
von Brandstiftung bezeichnet sie die Tat
als menschenverachtend
Finanzministerin Nancy und dann müssen
wir prüfen wer es dafür verantwortlich
und die Antwort des Staates ist dann
eine sehr harte wir werden mit allen
Mitteln des Rechtsstaates durchgreifen
die Tat muss verfolgt werden das muss zu
einer schnellen Anklage kommen und dann
auch zu einer Verurteilung Gutachter von
Staatsschutz und Kriminalpolizei
untersuchen die Brandruine die Behörden
rechnen mit konkreten Ergebnissen Anfang
nächster Woche
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung wird
teurer der Zusatzbeitrag den die
Krankenkassen erheben können steigt wohl
um 0,3 Punkte auf
1,6%. so sieht es das sogenannte
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach vor dass
der Bundestag heute abgesegnet hat der
Gesamtbeitrag könnte damit auch im
Schnitt 16,2% des Bruttolohns klettern
so sei das im nächsten Jahr erwartete
Milliardendefizit ausgeglichen werden
es ist ein Dilemma für viele junge
Eltern sie wollen wieder arbeiten gehen
finden aber keinen Kitaplatz und das
obwohl es einen Rechtsanspruch gibt nach
einer Prognose der Bertelsmannstiftung
fehlen im kommenden Jahr bundesweit gut
383.000 Kitaplätze dabei zeigt sich ein
Gefälle zwischen den Bundesländern in
Ostdeutschland gibt es einen Bedarf von
etwa 21.000 zusätzlichen Plätzen dort
war die Betreuungsquote schon immer
besser als im Westen wo im nächsten Jahr
362.000 Plätze fehlen könnten besonders
betroffen Nordrhein-Westfalen dort die
Färber
Carlo hat Glück gehabt mit einem Platz
in der Kita Löwenzahn schwer genug ist
das sagen die Eltern
hab mich bei 13 Kitas beworben für einen
Platz also war auf 13 Wartelisten es ist
sehr schwierig es ist wirklich also die
Kita hat selbst gesagt dass ein
Lotteriegewinn einen Platz zu kriegen
auf den Kita-Platz sind viele angewiesen
denn ohne den klappt meist die Rückkehr
in den Job nicht es fehlen aber
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher um diesen
Bedarf zu decken müssten laut Studie
99.000 Fachkräfte neu eingestellt werden
94.000 im Westen und 5000 im Osten
Deutschlands der Bedarf der Eltern an
Betreuung ist in den letzten Jahren
immer weiter gewachsen und deswegen
reicht der Ausbau der bisher
stattgefunden hat nicht aus obwohl es
inzwischen fast doppelt so viele
Fachkräfte gibt es bleiben eben zu wenig
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher auch in der
Kita Löwenzahn haben sie schließlich
keine neuen mehr gefunden
eine Gruppe geschlossen wir haben
einfach halt dann auch irgendwann kein
Personal mehr und wir wollen natürlich
auch in einer guten Qualität bleiben sie
wollen mit Kindern unter guten
Bedingungen arbeiten das verdienen die
Kleinsten und natürlich auch die großen
aber oft sind es zu wenig Leute im Team
das Schrecker ab
Münsters Berufs ist attraktiver machen
wir müssen den Menschen mehr bezahlen
wir müssen ihnen mehr Möglichkeiten
bieten sich weiterzuentwickeln denn für
Arbeit mit Kindern interessieren sich
eigentlich viele denn die kann richtig
Spaß machen
zum DFB-Pokal Norbert es war ein
packendes Spiel gestern Abend der Bayern
sie ging Augsburg
mittendrin war alles offen die Bayern
mit Mühe aber verdient im Achtelfinale
übrigens das erste mal wieder seit zwei
Jahren die Augsburger Bayern Bezwinger
in der Liga Verlierer im Pokal aber mit
erhobenem Haupt
Eric maxime-moting steuert zwei Tore bei
zum Bayern Sieg es sind die nicht ganz
unwichtigen um die starken Augsburger in
Schach zu halten die gehen schnell durch
Mats Petersen in der neunten Minute in
Führung zum großen Ärger von Bayern
Trainer Julian nagelsmann
doch chupa-motings Ausgleich in der 27
Minute kann die Münchner Gemüter wieder
beruhigen Augsburg hat sicherlich auch
ein bisschen über Paste die Räume wurden
dann schon größer also sie haben schon
für diese erste Viertelstunde auch
Tribut sollen müssen dem flotten 2:1
nach der Pause durch Josua Kimmich lässt
Choupo-Moting dann bald das 3:1 folgen
ein klares Ergebnis zeichnet sich ab das
ist Unterschied gemacht hat glaube ich
die zwei schneller Tore nach dem
Halbzeit das darf nicht passieren dass
es dann zu einfach vor allem gegen
Bayern ein Eigentor von upamecano lässt
die Bayern noch mal kurz zittern bevor
Jamal muschialla und in der
Nachspielzeit Alfonso Davies auf 5:2
erhöhen die Bayern eine Runde weiter
nach Gladbach am Dienstag gegen
Darmstadt scheiterte gestern Abend auch
Bundesligist Bremen an einer Zweitliga
Topmannschaft nämlich ein Paderborn
2:2 nach Verlängerung dann
Elfmeterschießen der Bremer Leonardo
Bittencourt verschießt danach behält
Rhythmen touchy die Nerven und versenkt
die Kugel zum fünf zu vier für Paderborn
der SC und vier weitere Zweitligisten im
Achtelfinale
ja und ebenfalls im Achtelfinale die
Handballer aus Flensburg Handewitt im
DHB-Pokal die SG setzte sich mit 34 zu
32 ging die Füchse Berlin durch und
fügte dem Hauptstadtclub die erste
pflichtspiel-niedergabe der Saison so
bester Werfer beim viermaligen
Pokalgewinner Emil Jacobsen mit zehn
Treffern
das Wetter wird morgen mild aber nass
genaues erfahren Sie gleich von
Christopher
Slomka begrüßt sie um 21 auf 45 zum
heute-journal auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend zweigeteilt war es heute im
Osten schien die Herbstsonne im Westen
wurde es schon nass und immer wieder
ziehen jetzt Schauer von Südwest nach
Nordost über uns hinweg besonders morgen
denn da überquert uns ein kleines
Randtief das bringt schauerartigen Regen
den haben wir auch schon in der Nacht im
Nordwesten und Südwesten sind einzelne
Gewitter möglich im Osten und Südosten
regnet es vorerst noch am wenigsten hier
ist es auch nicht mehr so kalt wie in
der vergangenen Nacht die Werte sinken
auf 6 Grad im Westen bleiben wir teils
bei 15 Grad morgen ist es im Nordosten
deutlich milder als heute meist 18 bis
20 Grad nur noch auf Rügen gibt es 13
Grad im Südwesten sind wieder über 20
Grad möglich es ist also mild morgen
aber nass am Vormittag gibt es schon im
Norden Schauer dann einen trockeneren
Streifen schnell folgt von Südwesten
aber ein neuer Schwall langanhaltenden
Regens und tatkräftigerer Gewitter der
sich am Nachmittag habe dann über die
Mitte und auch in den Osten ausbreitet
dazu gibt es einen frischen Südwind und
auch die nächsten Tage werden windig am
Samstag verstärkt sich der Regen im
Süden noch einmal spätestens am Sonntag
ist es dann aber für alle trockener am
Montag gibt es erst wieder neue Schauer
und einzelne Gewitter und die
Höchstwerte erreichen weiter über 20
Grad tschüss